dire bonsoir bonsoir vous connaissez
adriana karembeu je la connais de vue
bien sûr maintenant vous êtes la
tradition mais je connais christian
depuis très longtemps depuis les juniors
de nantes avec jésus christian avant
elle a été difficile pour vous
ouais je savais pas c'est un peu
emmerdant
on comptait vous présenter l'un à
l'autre et tout mais là c'est un peu
raté
il était très beau déjà
très sérieux toujours voulait déjà
et il était surtout très bon footballeur
et nous on jouer contre lui c'était pas
toujours facile
général je n'ai jamais vu pendant les
matches regardez dans les tribunes ah
ouais c'est pas comme toi qui truste
entend regarder déjà pris un but est de
garder
ouah
je vais commencer au ballon goût des
parents ça marchait tellement bien qu'il
a fait comique parce que tout le monde
je disais wow la comique puis un jour il
a librement jefferson si les marseillais
qui
sépare
cantona qui manquent à marseille moi
j'aimerais bien si je vais dire un truc
là franchement je n'aurais jamais dit ça
même pas un mois ou deux mois avant mais
c'est vrai que guy roux même à marseille
ça pourrait
jamais ils m'ont toujours fait un
accueil formidable je sais pas pourquoi
chaque fois que je vais à marseille ils
ont le doigt comme ça
vous heureux de vous avoir longé pas
vous faire trop de compliments on a
envie de vous faire des compliments mais
j'ai pas envie de faire trop de
compliments d'abord parce que c'est pas
le genre de la maison puis ensuite parce
que vous avez dit les louanges abbès
l'homme oui diminue l'homme diminue de
la combativité voilà son bras douloureux
mais vous dis pas qu'on vous aimez vous
êtes formidables ne diminuait pas ma
combativité avec avec vous on en a
besoin bon alors quand on s'intéresse un
petit peu à votre personne
votre personnage devient beaucoup plus
clair en fait c'est à dire on s'aperçoit
dès qu'on étudiait un peu l'avis de guy
roux les ancêtres de guy roux on
s'aperçoit que finalement tout ça est
assez clair vous avez retrouvé des
traces de vos ancêtres jusqu'au 12ème
siècle aujourd'hui on est dans une dans
une soirée que moyen-âge je sais pas
comment dire
il ya un bon et un bouquin vous avez
retrouvé dans le château d'appoigny non
mais c'est vrai ce que je dis est alors
ce qu'on découvre en fait on est tout le
temps guy roux il a un bon votre
personnage dis pas que c'est la vérité
mais votre personnage aux guignols c'est
d'être un peu radin d'être un peu et en
fait vous avez des ancêtres écossais oui
c'est c'est ce qu'on m'a dit enfin de
l'historien qui m'a renseigné ma mère
s'appelait laurie voilà loris est un nom
écossaise à la danoise au ricoh c'est
parce que
le château de ré jeune c'était la
dernière garnison de charles le
téméraire c'était des soldats écossais
voilà on comprend mieux le sens de
l'économie d'ailleurs d'ailleurs je le
dis tout de suite comme ça on n'aurait
pas à le ressortir la sortie à la
prochaine émission j'ai envoyé ma note
de frais de voyage pour venir ici à
votre production
[Applaudissements]
je ne savais pas notre confrère comme
vous à jouer sur ce côté employé par les
guignols s'est étonné que j'ai envoyé la
note c'était la moindre des choses à un
moment vous avez voulu attaquer les
guignols et donner l'argent à une cause
humanitaire si vous avez dit gagnent de
l'argent avec moi y'a pas de raison
qu'il ne paye pas et l'argent je le
donnerais à une grande cause oui c'est
un petit peu c'était ma première idée
puis après je me suis aperçu que quand
je disais qu'il fallait qu'ils arrêtent
il en faisait plus donc j'ai un petit
peu insisté vrai elle ne s'est pas fait
finalement alors vous quand on continue
à chercher dans votre famille vos
ancêtres il y avait un ancêtre de guy
roux qui préférait prendre 50 coups de
fouet que donner ses récoltes seigneur
ça c'est une partie de votre personnage
et l'autre partie votre côté imaginer
mettre en place vérifier c'est que vous
êtes en fait un adepte de napoléon du
mais beaucoup d'appelés en est un de vos
aïeuls était grognards de napoléon il
était sergent dans la grande armée et il
a eu la légion d'honneur sur la bérézina
c'était le grand père de mon grand-père
donc pas tradition orale on est sûre il
a pris un coup de lances à la bérézina
il est revenue à pied il est arrivé sept
ans plus tard et on lui a dit napoléon
alors il a dit je sais pas vrai il est
parti à fontainebleau à pied toujours
bien sûr pour vérifier très grosse
influence de votre grand-père votre
grand-père le fameux grand père qui est
mort à 50 ans ont lutté maladie voulait
pas se coucher il dit il disait c'est
dans l'hélico moeurs flèche l'open de
coucher non il disait je tant que j'irai
dans le jardin à la mort ne me trouvera
pas et puis les quelques dernières
semaines ils pourraient plus sortir il a
dit là va me trouver et vous souvenez de
votre grand-père l'histoire de la deûle
ampoules électriques là quand vous avez
commencé à auxerre oui quand je suis
rentré je t'ai militaire en allemagne
quand je suis rentré
j'ai eu un studio au fait que le club
m'a trouvé mais le locataire précédent
avait enlevé les ampoules dans mon grand
père m'a prêté les ampoules du grenier
mais m'a dit faut que tu gagnes ta vie
avant le printemps parce qu'au printemps
je retourne au grenier pour me la rendre
un grande influence second père sur vous
n'en a surtout eu des bons principes
sont les bons principes c'est là que ça
vient vous pensez que j'ai mis en
évidence elles qui m'ont permis
d'avancer un petit peu là vous êtes
france profonde mais pas franchouillard
et ça je crois que c'est important de le
dire parce que par exemple quand on voit
vos déclarations sur l'immigration
vous avez un discours qui est très
tolérant vous dites la france est une
terre d'invasion la première génération
c'est toujours difficile les polonais
les italiens et les portugais mais
finalement ces gens là ont enrichi notre
notre pays oui parce que
géographiquement c'était c'est le bout
de l'europe c'est l'ouest de l'europe il
pouvait pas aller plus loin et par
exemple pour parler toujours d'histoire
de ma région la vallée de l'yonne et
dans les invasions barbares c'est elle
et ses notes c'était en gros des mongols
et on trouve encore des gens et les yeux
[ __ ] dans les campagnes ça fait
pourtant longtemps et donc je pense que
toutes ces invasions fait par les
mélanges ont fait les français et puis
bon ok maintenant ça vient il y en a
encore qui viennent de l'est je pense
volontiers en entier est très
désagréable mais nous avons des gens qui
viennent du sud maintenant il faut quand
même se rappeler que c'est d'abord nous
qui les avons envahi c'est nous qui
avons été chercher des colonies il
n'avait pas appelé donc on a une culture
commune qu'on a partagé avec eux et
maintenant avec les moyens modernes de
transport il arrive je pense que il faut
leur faire le meilleur accueil sort et
j'ai été habitué au lycée parce que nous
étions en lice et d'accueil de l'afrique
occidentale française il y avait dans
chaque dortoir où dans chaque classe 5
africains à peu près qu'ils étaient des
fils de riches et moi j'étais avec eux
leurs meilleurs copains c'était ceux qui
jouent au foot évidemment et en plus
comme ils étaient riches ils avaient des
costumes tellement que ça tu n'es pas
dans leurs armoiries l'on mettait dans
la mienne est comme ça je pourrais
sortir le samedi vous êtes tombés dans
le football très jeunes parce qu'un jour
guy roux il avait 6 ans on vous a dit
dessine-moi le paradis vous avez décidé
des pelouses des buttes et un ballon
donc oui je j'ai toujours j'avais dit au
curé aux catéchistes que le paradis ça
devait être un endroit il y avait plein
de terrain de foot avec ballon et
depuis on m'a proposé on m'a dit et tu
sera l'entraîneur du paradis c'est
gérard gili le plus tard possible bien
sûr et comme j'étais petit on vous
offrait des soldats de plomb nous
faisait deux équipes au lieu un avec une
bille qui ferait de ballons ça vous
arrive et pascal la guerre de juillet au
ballon j'étais enfant après la guerre
dont elle est jouée c'est
essentiellement des soldats de plomb
mais nous avec une bille on faisait des
équipes de foot avec le filet vous savez
les voiliers les films de l truffaut là
et les femmes avaient un filet pour le
chignon ouais alors je prenais des
filets de ma mère ça faisait les filets
de but et mon métier un grand soldat
dans les buts pour lyon metella cowboys
général ont bouché par la passe qu'il
plongeait sur leur sur la vie nous est
toujours été chef 1 à 13 ans était déjà
le petit chef vous occuper tout le monde
vous montiez les ballons ont nettoyé le
terrain vous l'aviez les shorts soigner
les joueurs widgets un petit peu
organisateurs des années plus tard quand
vous êtes à auxerre si vous aviez des
espions dont les boîtes de nuit pour
voir si les joueurs sortent et
non au début j'allais voir moi-même ah
bon malin malin
[Applaudissements]
non en prenant de l'âge
et les boîtes se multipliant j'ai
organisé un petit peu vous aviez un
réseau alors maintenant avec les
portables je vais vous dire c'est facile
portable si vous avez un analyseur
samedi
c'était un peu c'est un peu faire sur le
coup des rôdeurs chérie je vais voir
s'il ya des joueurs en boîte de nuit
j'en ai cherché jusqu'à 4 heures du
matin
enfin beaucoup pour sortir ça va mais
adriana ils le font à 42 ça dans sa
sangle s'il est sûr jamais à bon ok je
vais vous dire quand on vous à la maison
on sort pareil ça
sortirait plus jamais
les boîtes ferait faillite ouais alors
vous avez toujours été quand même très
préoccupé 1 par les copines des joueurs
tous à la taille des voitures y paraît
long c'est vrai c'est incroyable ça vous
aimiez pas que les joueurs sortent avec
des filles qui avaient des airs 5 ou des
fiat 500 parce que les mecs ce chopper
mal aux reins en [ __ ] dans la voiture
non c'est que à un moment on avait un
centre de formation depuis trois ans et
donc on avait eu délit évidemment un peu
à prix réduit et un jour tous les
plusieurs joueurs avait mal au dos alors
le directeur du centre me dis il faut
changer l'élite acheter des livres assez
bien faut changer les lire j'ai fait une
enquête ce qu'ils avaient tous les trois
une petite amie qui avait une fiat 500
vous avez des ruses aussi pour rentrer
dans les hôtels contient un joueur qui
vous intéressez vous faisiez pas si
serré comme par exemple en argentine je
crois y avait un joueur polonais qui
vous intéressait cette rentrée en vous
faisant passer pour un livreur de
boissons mais c'est à la coupe du monde
soixante dix huit l'équipe de pologne
était dans en altitude dans un col un
record d'altitude on augmente la faculté
de d'avoir des globules rouges c'est
d'une manière naturelle ce n'est pas la
même chose que c'est pas le pérou voilà
c'est ça mais ça fait le même effet et
donc l'équipe de pologne était dans un
col à 15 cents mètres dans un hôtel et
il y avait la troupe argentine qui
gardait c'était dans la cordillère des
andes le petit gars de la route c'était
impossible de passer moi je voulais
contacter harmach qui était le grand
grand avant-centre de l'époque eh bien
j'ai dit ces gens là à là haut ils
mangent ils boivent donc il ya des gens
qui leur portent la boisson j'ai trouvé
le livreur de bierges une casquette la
veste l'infernal selon le type quand je
suis arrivé où il m'a dit maintenant tu
met déjà
vous êtes international
[Applaudissements]
a signé chez nous
il a signé chez nous deux ans plus de
deux ans plus tard car les deux ans mais
n'avait le droit de sortir qu'à 30 ans à
ce moment là avant c'était du temps du
régime communiste et ce qui est oui
alors il ya quand même un peu le revers
de la médaille c'est à dire que vous
avez tout donné à auxerre va aussi
pratiquement la seule équipe dont vous
êtes occupé vous allez vous l'avez pris
à 0 et vous l'avez amener au plus haut
si vous a quand même coûté votre vie
affective non oh non non non j'ai une
vie affective qui doit correspondre à la
moyenne des des gens de notre société
actuelle non je ne me plains pas là
dessus je me plains pas du tout vous
n'êtes pas coûter votre mariage oh non
parce que ya des mariages qui vont pas
ou si c'est pas des entraîneurs de foot
assis avec les entraîneurs de foot alors
vous êtes posé une question un jour
c'est vrai qu'on peut se la poser
pourquoi tout le monde aime tellement le
foot alors il ya plusieurs explications
il ya le ballon rond pour puisque ça
rappelle le ventre de la mère et puis
après quand on est adolescent ça peut
faire penser à autre chose mais on déjà
bébé je me devais me croiser les bras
car on veut
quelqu'un j'ai dit j'ai dit vont d'abord
le évidemment le ventre de la mère de
l'enfant il commence dans une sphère
ensuite il va chercher son casse croûte
dans les sphères
ensuite quand il les adolescents comme
vous avez dit il a plutôt tendance à
s'en rapprocher encore bon ensuite
il ya la lune il ya la terre venu
beaucoup de se faire et je pense que
c'est une d une des choses qui attire
c'est pour ça que tout le monde le monde
entier est attiré par le ballon en ce
moment oui les jeux de ballons sont sans
mondiaux pas seulement le football le
basket aussi le volet qui sont des
transports mondiaux le handball mais le
rugby c'est le rugby c'est un autre type
de gonzesses
non mais bon personne ne saura jamais
pourquoi les philosophes peuvent essayer
de chercher karembeu il joue avec deux
ballons lui et alors
je suis vivant je suis d'accord d'accord
d'accord l'homme vous dites aussi que
l'homme quand il joue au ballon il
retrouve ses quatre membres alors c'est
pourquoi c'est vous pensez que c'est à
un retour de l'époque où mariah carey
des messages enfin moi je suis pas bien
étudié mais mais il semblerait un moment
qu'on n'ait eu des ancêtres qui avait un
peu des mains à la place des pieds un
très bon et tout d'un coup quand l'homme
s'est redressé les pieds non plus servi
qu'à qu'à marcher et à se tenir debout
oui c'est vrai qu'avant on attrape et
les branches avec les grilles avec les
quatre les 80 fixé le pied à diminuer
les qualités a diminué ses qualités a
perdu des qualités et le football c'est
l'activité humaine qui a permis de
rendre le pied intelligent
tout le monde vous croient comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et enfin que vous êtes
guy roux à l'appel le sorcier
bourguignon je sais que j'ai mis
sympathy for the devil parce qu'on vous
appelle le sorcier bourguignon est alors
c'est vrai que vous avez un don mais
c'est vrai de voyance à attendait guy
d'abord je vais citer quelques exemples
très très précis tout le monde peut
vérifier fait le service militaire en
allemagne
un jeu vous allez voir votre supérieur
hiérarchique le gradé dit il faut que je
m'en aille pourquoi ma mère vient de
mourir c'était vrai et vous saviez pas
le terril arrivée le lendemain je pense
que beaucoup de gens ont ce genre de
abords de prémonition ne disent pas moi
je lâche et un jour et puis c'est
répéter mais je pense que ça arrive à
beaucoup de monde ça est votre joueur là
michel ngom là vous étiez le premier sur
les lieux un jour c'est le hasard alors
vous est ce que c'est le hasard je vois
pas ce qu il paraît que vous prédisiez
bien les résultats des matchs le score
le nom du buteur les circonstances du
but ça m'arrive je ne le dit jamais et
puis ça ça n'arrive pas toujours parfois
il ya des erreurs mais quand même dans
des matchs très forts des matches où dix
finales ceci fait suite à un souci paix
dans la faculté d'anticipation a
exacerbé de voilà que c'est juste pour
dire
ce qui veut dire qu'ils venir avec un
fort je vais me concentrer sur un match
vous finissez par parlant sentir
complètement récemment le prévoir
je sors si bourguignon bien alors
attention maintenant on va vous faire
une interview
proverbe mais vous savez qu'on ne bouge
pas pendant le génial
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parfait bio voilà voilà je dis ça je dis
ça pour l'embellie laurent si tu nous
regardes de son lieu de vacances avec
les gosses c'est à ce que des gens comme
guy roux ne bouge pas eu voilà c'est
tout ce que je voulais dire alors
l'interview proverbe attention vous êtes
prêts est ce que vous pensez guy roux
que tant va la cruche à l'eau qu'à la
fin elle se casse
oui
croyez vous qu'on puisse être au four et
au moulin non
faut-il absolument ménages et s'aventure
quand on veut voyager loin oui
estimez vous que la paresse et la mère
de tous les vices
non
pourquoi il ya tout ce qu il yad autres
mère de tous les vices ah oui sûrement
ouais plus grave plus grave que
l'appareil par exemple
la tendance à la malhonnêteté vers l'est
la paresse c'est une c'est une négation
mais c'est pas vraiment une faute en soi
bien moi je trouve c'est pas un défaut
il a construit toute sa carrière sur la
sur la paresse il se donne du mal pour
être je peux vous dire est ce que vous
pensez qu'ils roulent que pour vivre
heureux il faut vivre caché
ben non parce que ça c'est pas ma vie je
vais pas vous cacher je serais pas venu
soir ouais ça c'est vrai on est content
que vous soyez là ça me fait très
plaisir mais soyez moi je dirai après si
j'étais qui vaille est franchement que
pierre qui roule ne peut pas amassé
mousse
non
ouais vous n'êtes pas toujours d'accord
avec la sagesse populaire avec la non
parce que vous savez vous me dites vous
me donnez des proverbes il ya très
souvent le proverbe inverse ouais alors
vous m'en donnez un mois je préfère
l'autre il est malin
est-ce que vous pensez que bien mal
acquis ne profite jamais oui oui ça
d'accord est-ce que tout vient à point à
qui sait attendre
oui va être presque toujours c'est comme
le proverbe chinois assieds toi à bord
de la rivière et tu verra passer le
cadavre de ton pire ennemi quoi c'est ça
un peu oui rend bien chinois celui-là
vous avez des proverbes comme ça de
rihanna dans votre pays
belinda au boulot ce serait
un mensonge à des petites jambes ah oui
je sais c'est qu'en même temps on ne
sait pas qui est d'ailleurs excusé moi
c'est vous êtes slovaque
non non allez c'est quoi la différence
se bat pas la différence non ça veut
dire quoi message à des petites jambes
j'ai pas compris ça je sais pas si tout
le monde a compris le hockey voilà
qu'est ce qui veut dire la signification
de mensonges et des petites jambes ça
veut dire quoi
si vous mentez vous n'avez pas très loin
[Applaudissements]
et
si la sagesse novak vient alors guy roux
dernière question est-ce que mieux vaut
tard que jamais ou vieux motard que
j'aimais
répondez vous êtes plus tard que jamais
merci
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux